a lot of people on Twitter have been
laughing at the fact that these people
died because they're wealthy and we
discussed that a little bit on last
night's show so we probably don't have
to retread that territory but I want to
open it up to you guys what do you guys
think about this what do you guys think
about the fact that the Navy says that
they heard or detected that there was a
whole implosion several days ago and
didn't say anything until now whole
whole implosion yes because when I first
heard you I thought you said whole no no
yeah yeah I'm not sure what that would
even mean no because the hole is
like a complete the whole cracked and
they found debris I think about a third
of a mile from the wreckage of the
Titanic so
the Wall Street Journal is reporting
that this uh U.S Navy technology that's
used to find an enemy submarines picked
up on what they now believed was this
implosion around the area where debris
was now found